le combat des chauffeurs de taxis contre
le service de covoiturage
hubert est loin d'être terminée à
montréal le regroupement qui représente
4000 chauffeurs et propriétaires de taxi
a déposé ce matin une demande
d'injonction permanente pour rendre
illégal ce service de transport dans
toute la province
montréal est donc à l'avant-plan de ces
villes qui font barrage à hubert avec
donc une situation assez explosive ici
meilleurs au canada hubert fait quand
même quand même une certaine acceptation
on pense à edmonton qui a légalisé ce
service oui donc une première canadienne
edmonton qui a décidé d'encadrer avec
une législation bien précises le
phénomène
hubert est donc qu'est-ce qu'elle impose
la ville d'edmundston à hubert et aux
autres services similaires et bien c'est
d'abord un permis d'exploitation de 70
mille dollars par an des assurances pour
tous les conducteurs qui font partie du
bear un prix plancher donc un prix
minimum de 3 $ et 25 et une taxe de 600
par utilisateur et ça c'est attendu avec
beaucoup d'impatience par d'autres
villes qui songent également emboîté le
pas à cette légalisation
c'est le cas notamment de toronto or on
sait que john terry le maire de toronto
s'est toujours montrée assez assez
enclin à autoriser ce genre de service
là et puis calgary qui a banni par
injonction le service hubert en novembre
dernier pense maintenant dans les
prochaines semaines à mettre sur la
table une législation pour encadrer cela
suppose que tout le monde observe ce qui
se passe donc à edmonton
c'est une entreprise américaine qui est
basée à san francisco on imagine qu aux
états unis il ya plus d'acceptabilité
sociale de ce service de covoiturage et
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est
qu'en fait quand on regarde le nombre
d'états qui autorise déjà hubert en fait
on arrive maintenant à 27 états dans la
caroline du nord le maine le colorado et
le nevada dans les municipalités
maintenant eh bien c'est presque une
cinquantaine chicago détroit orlando et
washington ont dit oui à hubert donc on
a décidé d'aller plus loin et en fait ce
n'est qu'un début parce que par exemple
à seattle il ya quelques semaines en
fait on a même octroyé le droit de
syndicalisation pour les chauffeurs qui
sont qui travaille pour hubert même si
ce ne sont finalement que des
indépendants auxtin pas déjà en avant et
puis en californie un important recours
collectif pour donner à ses shows furent
là le statut de salarié évidemment il ya
une grande bataille devant les tribunaux
qui s'organise parce qu hubert ne
bien savoir de ça sinon ça veut dire que
ses coûts d'opération irait beaucoup
plus on voit que ça avance quand même
sur la l'encadrement nous avons c'est
évidemment la cible principale les
chauffeurs de taxi dans des villes comme
montréal et la question c'est est-ce que
ce service est là pour rester ici mais
ce n'est qu'un début en fait quand on
regarde ce qui se passe par exemple
justement aux états unis on a general
motors qui vient d'investir 700 millions
de dollars dans la principale
concurrente d'hubert ça s'appelle lift
et l'idée c'est qu'on veut utiliser la
base de données de lift de covoiturage
pour essayer de repousser le plus
possible le projet de voiture autonome
c'est-à-dire les voitures sans
conducteur imaginez vous donc et puis on
apprenait récemment que facebook a
déposé un brevet pour essayer en fait de
mettre en contact beaucoup de gens pour
faire du covoiturage et rien ne les
empêchera d'aller plus loin pour devenir
le concurrent méga concurrents d'hubert
avec une base de données d'un milliard
400 millions d'utilisateurs potentiels
six énormes beaucoup d utilisateurs
potentiels merci frédéric langlais